you do wonder what they say to them
ahead of a moment like this and if mum
and dad are actually more nervous with
the cameras watching George Louis and
Charlotte did seem on best behavior it
wasn't quite their first day but time to
meet some of the other pupils and the
teachers
welcome and welcome Charlotte lovely to
have you with with us and probably a
chance for the other parents to get over
the shock that they may well see these
two at the school Gates
only one TV Camera one reporter and one
photographer were allowed in for that
moment and yes it is an element of
control to try to keep things low-key
but coming from two parents who
increasingly seem to realize that they
can't entirely keep their children
hidden away
[Applause]
Brothers in check it felt like a step in
their education for a life in the public
eye but of course school will also play
A Part
the school will prepare them for a life
of public duty in that it has a very
socially conscious feel to it Jonathan
Perry is incredibly focused on ensuring
that um his pupils
understand their situation that they all
understand their privilege and you know
let's be under No Illusion we're talking
about an incredibly privileged cohort
here
lambrook which is just outside Windsor
describes itself as a school that helps
their pupils from 3 to 13 become
confident intelligent and creative young
people and that would have ticked a lot
of boxes for William and Kate
life of course will never be completely
normal they are trying to make sure
though they don't get special treatment
especially from the head teacher and
with that the focus was on settling in
and time for the cameras to go Rihanna
Mills Sky News in Berkshire